[Music]
welcome to the first ever flutter video
on this channel today we'll start from
scratch and build a user authentication
system using firebase Google sign-in and
firestore the UI is nothing special but
this video is important because it will
show you how to handle real-time streams
of data from external sources and update
the UI reactively if you're new here
like and subscribe and you can grab the
full source code from fire ship IO I'd
like to start by saying that this video
is intermediate level so if you're brand
new to flutter it might seem a little
overwhelming but don't worry because
next week I have a more gentle
introduction plan that's specifically
for JavaScript and/or typescript
developers who are starting from scratch
so the first thing we'll do is run
flutter create from the command line to
create a new app we can then open up the
app in vs code and we'll have some
configuration to do for the platform's
we want to use in this case we'll only
be setting up Android but the iOS setup
is super easy so feel free to do that if
you're on a Mac from here we'll jump
into the firebase console click on the
Android button and then we'll need to
set a package ID for our project that
should be something like calm you're a
company name followed by the app name so
IO dot fire shipped lesson app in this
case the next thing we want to do is
generate a signing certificate
specifically for Google OAuth we can
generate it by copying and pasting this
command I'll link that in the full
lesson and then going to the terminal
and entering the command I'm not sure if
this is a problem on my end or if the
command is just outdated but it gives me
an error if I try to use export cert and
list together if it works for you then
that's great but if not you'll want to
go in here and take out the list from
the command and then when prompted for a
password type in Android and all
lowercase and finally copy and paste the
same command but this time delete export
cert from it that should give you an
sha-1 certificate that you can just copy
and paste in there and then click the
next step and that will give us our
Google services JSON file we can
download it and save it in the Android
app directory inside of our flutter
project now getting back to vs code
we'll go into that Android directory it
should look something like this and then
we'll open up the build Gradle file
inside of the app directory inside this
file you'll see the application ID we'll
want to switch that to the application
ID that we chose on firebase
and down at the very bottom we will
apply the plugin that's required for
Google services and lastly we need to go
up one level to the Android directory
and you'll see another build Gradle file
there and this one we need to find the
dependencies and then add the class path
that references the Google services
plug-in then the final thing we'll do is
go into the pub spec Y amel and add our
actual dependencies for this project for
a firebase mobile app you'll almost
always need firebase core and analytics
and then we'll also bring in firestore
firebase auth and Google sign in is its
own plugin and lastly I'm adding rx dart
which is optional but it gives you a lot
of power when working with real time
streams in firebase and we'll see you
direct examples of that throughout this
lesson at this point let's go ahead and
run flutter run just to make sure we
don't have any errors in the console or
in the app itself that should give us
the default flutter app that looks
something like this from here we're
going to transform this app into a login
button that reacts to the user's
authentication state in addition this
feature will save any custom data that
we want to the firestore database for
example we might want to customize the
user profile with a unique user name or
some other unique data or we might have
additional relational data that we need
to query based on the user's user ID
okay so now let's write some code first
I'm going into the main dart file and
I'm just going to delete pretty much
everything in here the only thing I want
to keep is the my app widget just so we
have a container to display our button
so inside the material app you'll see a
body property and in that we can go
ahead and set up a child that is a
column and the reason I'm using a column
here is because we can add multiple
widgets to it and I'll just be stacked
on top of each other so basically what
we're going to do is just flush out our
UI inside this widget array we're going
to need two different buttons we'll have
one to sign-in with Google and then one
to sign out every material button has an
on pressed event handler that we can
implement to do something when the user
clicks on a button right now it does
nothing but we'll set that up in the
next step then we'll go ahead and set up
a second material button this one will
be to logout when the user is
authenticated it's the exact same widget
just with some different coloring and
text so if we run the app at this point
you should see the two buttons up here
at the top of the view if we want to
Center our buttons we can actually
into the coulomb widget and adjust the
main axis alignment to center and that
puts our buttons in the middle now it's
time to switch gears and talk about the
authentication logic it's generally a
good idea to separate your business
logic from your UI or presentation logic
and that's exactly what we're going to
do here by creating a new file called
off dart now flutter is not very
opinionated about the way you share
global data or handle your state
management and you'll see a lot of
examples out there that use redux or
inherited widgets but when you're just
prototyping and one of the easiest
things to do is just expose a global
variable so that's what we're going to
do here by creating an auth class and
then we'll go ahead and and Stan she ate
that as our off service and just have
that sit in the global namespace it's
not a true singleton but we will only
instantiate it once and it will live
outside of our actual widget tree inside
the class itself we'll start by defining
some private members for firebase and
Google sign-in then the actual values
that will be available to our widgets
will all be either observables or
streams and it's also important that
they are multi subscription streams or
hot observables in dart a stream is only
able to handle one subscription by
default but we want to share these
streams and potentially many different
widgets globally throughout the app so
that's an important rule to follow if
you're exposing a global stream the
observable user is the user that we get
from firebase authentication while the
profile is the custom user data that we
save about that user in the database and
lastly we'll create a subject for the
loading state which is just an
observable that we can push new values
to manually so these 3 streams define
our state and then we'll have our
widgets listen to them and then update
the UI reactively the next thing we'll
do is just go over all the methods that
are available on this service Google
sign-in will be used when the user taps
a button and it will take them to their
Google account so they can log in and
authenticate update user data will
update that users record in fire store
and sign out will sign the user out of
firebase the first thing we'll do is go
up here to the constructor and define
the user observable so by default
firebase is already giving this to us as
a stream so we can just wrap it inside
of observable and that will change any
time the user signs in or signs out now
in order to retrieve the user's profile
from fires store we first need to know
the value of their user ID
this is where our X start is going to
start making our life a lot easier
because we can just use this switch map
operator which will listen to the value
of the user observable then it will
switch to a different observable in this
case the observable of the firestore
data for that user so we can just point
to the users collection grab the
document with the corresponding user ID
grab the snapshots and then I'm also
going to map the snapshots to their
actual data payload just for convenience
here when the users not signed in we're
not going to have a user ID so in that
case we want to return some observable
data from switch map which we can do
with observable just and an empty object
so that gives us observables we can
listen to in the widgets now we just
need a way for the user to sign in as
soon as the user clicks on the Google
sign-in button we're going to flip the
loading state to true and we can do that
by simply calling add on our loading
stream then the next thing we'll do is
just follow the steps required to get
the user signed in so first we will call
the Google sign-in method and that will
trigger the sign-in process once that's
completed it will give us the user's ID
token and off token at this point the
user will be signed in with Google but
not firebase but we can easily sign them
in to firebase by just taking the tokens
and then passing them to the Google
sign-in method from firebase off then
we'll update their user data and
firestore which we'll implement here in
the next step and then we'll flip the
loading state to false the reason I put
this in a separate method is that if you
have multiple sign-in options you can
reuse this code for each of them and
basically we're just making a reference
to the same firestore document and then
we're calling ref set data with whatever
custom data we want to put in there
I'm going to add a timestamp of the
current date just so we can see that
update when we sign-in and sign-out and
adding the merge true option will make
this a non-destructive update so it
won't overwrite any existing user data
in that document and lastly we can just
call off sign out to sign out the user
so that takes care of our business logic
for authentication now we can get to the
really cool part which is making flutter
reactive well look at two different ways
we can make the UI update when the
values and those streams change the
first one we'll look at is a stateful
widget which works very similar to a
react.js component if you're familiar
with react but first we'll go into the
buttons that we defined earlier and
implement they're on press the event
handler
that's as simple as calling off service
Google sign-in and sign-out inside of
these functions at this point you should
be able to sign into the app with your
Google account and when you do that you
should also see the data updated in
firestore the first thing we'll do is
define a new widget called the user
profile that extends stateful widget the
only thing this widget needs to do is
call the create state method for the
user profile state the next step is to
define the state which is the user
profile state and it extends the state
class with the user profile that we just
defined now this widget can listen to
our global streams and then set its own
internal state that we can actually show
in the UI in this demo I'm just going to
be really lazy with the UI and we'll
just show the user profile and the
loading state is a string now when you
set up listeners on a stream or
observable you usually want to make sure
that the state is initialized which you
can do inside the anit state life cycle
hook so all we have to do here is called
the auth service profile listen that
will set up the subscription and then
that will give us the state from that
subscription and then we'll use it to
call set state on the stateful widget
set state is important and it's built
into stateful widgets and it just tells
the widget to re-render when it's called
so you should only use set State to
update values on the widget all the
computation should be done outside of it
then we can go ahead and do the exact
same thing for the loading state from
the off service and now the UI for this
widget will rerender any time the values
in these streams change now we don't
have any UI and this widget yet so let's
go ahead and add that inside of its
build function again I'm being super
lazy with the UI here so I'm just
setting up a column that has a container
then we'll render out the underlying
data as text widgets so this is nice for
debugging but obviously not what you
want in a real app when we log in we
should see this object that's the data
from fire store and then below that we
have false for the loading state you'll
notice that even though we're logged in
we're still showing both the login
button and the logout button instead of
doing that in a stateful widget we can
actually do it in a state list widget
using a thing called a stream builder
you'll also notice that it has a lot
less complexity and boilerplate code
than the stateful widget the stream
builder is a widget itself that takes
two arguments the first one is the
stream to listen to and then the second
one is a function that will return some
UI elements based on the state of the
stream so for our login button we
want to listen to the user observable
and then if the users logged in we'll
show the sign out button if not we'll
show the sign-in with Google button so
the Builder function gives you two
things to work with the context and then
the snapshot of the stream itself in our
case the snapshot will be the user so we
can see if the user has data then we
know that the user is logged in
otherwise we know that users logged out
so we can actually just go and grab the
material buttons that we already created
then put them into the corresponding
spot in this conditional so now whenever
the stream emits a new value it will
just automatically rerender based on
this logic in the Builder function I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe and I'm really curious to get
your feedback on this video my plan is
to make a lot more flutter videos in the
future but it's really based on what you
guys want to see make sure to grab the
full source code from fire ship IO
thanks for watching and I will talk to
you soon